i don't want to spend a ton of time on
this because i believe there's going to
be more time for it but one of the big
questions about 2024 is
is joe biden going to run for
re-election i think he's not that's my
opinion as of right now but i could be
wrong it's just a guess i'm terrible at
making predictions i thought hillary
would win in 2016. so it's just my
opinion and it doesn't really matter i
just don't think joe biden's running for
re-election in 2024. the other side of
that is is trump running for re-election
in 2024
i have been leaning very heavily towards
yes for a while when i interviewed
michael cohen trump's former lawyer
michael cohen said i don't think trump's
going to run because he's going to
realize he can't win and his ego can't
handle another loss okay that's another
opinion
but one of the things i've been
mentioning is
i am unsure what trump's health is going
to look like in 2024. he's not a healthy
guy and he's not a particularly young
guy okay just it's just actuarial
realities fair um for the first time
that i've ever seen donald trump is now
starting to talk about his health as a
possible reason that he wouldn't run and
the question is regardless of the truth
about his health is he just starting to
lay the groundwork for using health as
an excuse not to run this is from an
interesting interview in the washington
post with josh dossey
this was from um
this was from a few days ago the article
is called trump deflects blame for
january 6 silence
says he wanted to march to the capitol
i don't want to talk about that part of
it i want to talk specifically about the
end of this article where trump actually
talks about the issue of 2024 and health
check this out let's put it up on the
screen
trump said it was true he had told
advisors that his health would factor
into whether he would run again in 2024
but that he was currently in good health
quote you always have to talk about
health you look like you're in good
health but tomorrow you get a letter
from a doctor saying come see me again
that's not good when they use the word
again so this is typical trump speak
where we're like left wondering is is he
saying this because he already knows
about a health issue or not or does he
just what what is this about it's it's
cryptic it's always completely cryptic
but this is the first time i'm aware of
that donald trump has floated what will
his health status be in 2024
as a factor now i've been saying it's a
factor obviously if he's not healthy
he's not going to be able to run but
trump is now laying it out there and
there's two perspectives one is there's
something going on with trump and this
is how he's starting to allude to it the
second perspective is
this is just setting up an excuse but
trump has no intention of running what
trump wants to do is to continue
dangling that he might run the way he's
been doing at rallies saying you're
going to be very happy in 2024 we're
gonna take it back in 2024 suggesting
that he's going to run in order to keep
fundraising for his pack which is pretty
clearly being used as a slush fund to
hire family members and who knows what
else he has millions of reasons right
now to pretend that he's going to run in
2024 and he may not even really be
planning to do it we just don't know
what we do know is health which i've
been talking about for over a year now
actually being mentioned by trump as far
as i know for the first time uh we'll
have more coverage of this interview on
our instagram at david pakman show and
you can let us know there in a comment
what do you think is the meaning of this
health issue
being brought up by trump for the first
time let us know
one of our longtime sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for quality watches
sunglasses and more
serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release
is no exception it's the argo automatic
it spotlights everything i love about
vincero i got the argo automatic in
frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but i really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out i love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face i really
love all of their watches and i own a
bunch but the argo is probably my
favorite so far vincero sunglasses and
jewelry and other accessories are
awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero collective is giving my audience
15 percent off all products and free
shipping go to vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below